continúa siendo el epicentro mundial de
la pandemia y su situación cada vez es
más crítica en las últimas 24 horas
brasil superó los 330 mil muertos por
ccoo y 19 sin embargo en el momento más
difícil de la pandemia para esa nación
la justicia autorizó la realización de
cultos y misas en todo el territorio
este sábado el ex presidente luiz inácio
lula da silva que en días pasados acusó
al presidente ya ir bolsonaro de ser
responsable del peor genocidio del país
recibió la segunda dosis de su vacuna e
hizo un nuevo llamado al gobierno
solo tiene que hacer una cosa escuchar
la ciencia a aquellos que saben y
cumplir las determinaciones
y minas
por su parte chile continúa en medio de
la llamada mega cuarentena que mantiene
confinada a más del 83 por ciento de la
población pese a las medidas y a la
avanzada campaña de vacunación que vive
el país y que ha permitido inocular a
cerca de 7 millones de personas el
sábado en la nación superó por segundo
día consecutivo la barrera de los 8.000
positivos este lunes inicia el cierre de
fronteras que durará al menos hasta el
final de abril la vacuna se transforma
en una alternativa de salida a este gran
problema pero también se transforma en
la causa de otro problema es decir esta
comunicación tan triunfalista respecto
de que somos el país que más rápido
vacuna que somos felicitado
internacionalmente que vamos a lograr la
inmunidad primero que nadie mandó una
señal a las personas respecto de un
cierto relajo entretanto argentina
recibió con sorpresa la noticia del
contagio del presidente alberto
fernández a quien se le aplicaron las
dos dosis de la vacuna rusa sputnik de
en principio el jefe de estado dio
positivo a un test de antígeno y el
resultado fue confirmado por una prueba
psa
de acuerdo con la información oficial el
mandatario se encuentra estable y es
asintomático
[Aplausos]